is there something you can say about the
standard models of the four laws of
physics that seems to work very well and
uh
yet people are striving to do more
talking about unification so on why
what's wrong what's broken about the
standard model
why why does it need to be improved i
mean the thing which gets most attention
is um
is gravity that we have trouble um
so you wanna you wanna in some sense
integrate
integrate what we know about the
gravitational force with it and have a
unified quantum field theory that has
gravitational interactions also so
that's the big problem everybody talks
about um
i mean
but but it's also true that if you look
at the standard model it has these very
very deep beautiful ideas but
there's certain aspects of it that are
very
that are let's just say that they're not
beautiful they're not um
you have to to make the thing work you
have to throw in
lots and lots of extra parameters at
various points
um and a lot of this has to do with the
so-called uh
you know the so-called higgs mechanism
in the higgs field that if you look at
the theory it's
everything is if you forget about the
higgs field and what it needs to do
the rest of the theory is
is very very constrained and has very
very few free parameters really a very
small number there's a very small number
of parameters and a few integers which
tell you what the theory is
to make this work as a theory of the
real world you need a higgs field and
you need to
it needs to do
to do something
and
once you introduce that higgs field all
sorts of parameters
make an appearance so now we've got
20 or 30 or whatever whatever parameters
that are going to tell you what all the
masses of things are and what's going to
happen so you've gone from
a very tightly constrained thing with a
couple parameters to uh
this this thing which the minute you put
it in you had to add all this extra
all these extra parameters to make
things work and so that
it may be one argument as well that's
just the way the world is and
the fact that you don't find that
aesthetically pleasing is just your
problem or
maybe we live in a multiverse and those
numbers are just different in every
universe
but but you know another
reasonable conjecture is just that well
this is just telling us that there's
something we don't understand about
what's going on in a deeper way which
would explain those numbers and there's
some kind of
deeper idea about where the higgs field
comes from and what's going on
which we haven't figured out yet and
that's
that's what we should look for but
you